Olá pessoal aqui Dr Alan Machado Dutra
para mais um vídeo é um prazer estar
falando com vocês vamos falar hoje sobre
o sal palmeto é um dos Suplementos
naturais mais consumidos por homens
enfrentando câncer de próstata ou
hiperplasia prostática benigna É
valorizado por seus efeitos na regulação
hormonal e no controle do crescimento da
próstata além de seus usos principais o
sal pometo serve como remédio natural
para uma variedade de condições
resfriados tose dor de garganta asma um
bronquite S síndrome da dor pélvica
crônica em xaque seca também conhecido
por melhorar o fluxo unário promover o
relaxamento e aumentar o desejo sexual
bem pessoal o que que é o sal palmeto
ele é uma planta nativa do sudeste dos
Estados Unidos também conhecido como
serenoa happens pode crescer até 3 m de
altura apresenta folhas pontudas que se
distribuem em forma de leque as bagas
roxas extraídas dessa Palmeira são
utilizadas para produzir o extrato do
sal Palmeira
essas frutas que são parecidas com
Amoras pretas azuladas são ricas em
propriedades anti-inflamatórias
diuréticas anti androgênicas e os grácos
tornando útil para tratar condições como
queda de cabelo impotência e aumento
Benigno da próstata Então vamos falar
dos três benefícios mais impressionantes
do sal pometo primeiro tratamento da
hiperplasia prostática benigna ou
crescimento Benigno da próstata que é
caracterizado pelo aumento não
cancerígeno do órgão sendo a forma mais
prevalente de aumento prostático a
próstata pode crescer devido a uma
combinação de alterações hormonais
notavelmente o excesso de estrogênio
deterioração dos vasos sanguíneos e
deficiência de zinco Então à medida que
a prosta aumenta de tamanho ela pode
inflamar ou aumentar de tamanho sem
tanta inflamação comprimindo a uretra
isso geralmente resulta em dificuldade
urinar o que pode levar à dor e
complicações como infecções do trato
urinário formação de cálculos na bexiga
os sintomas típicos são dificuldade de
iniciar mixão jato fraco e sensação de
esvaziamento incompleto da bexiga Então
como é que nós fazemos para tratar isso
o tratamento convencional É os
bloqueadores Alfa adren éticos e os
inibidores da cinco Alfa redutase são
prescritos para reduzir os sintomas da
doença Mas podem causar efeitos
colaterais significativos inclusive
problemas sexuais disfunções sexuais
então aí que entra o sal Palmeira que
tem compostos que inibem a ação da
enzima 5 alfa redutase sem causar
disfunção sexual reduzindo a conversão
do hormônio testosterona em de
hidrotestosterona DHT que está
relacionado ao aumento desse órgão da
próstata Então quais são as vantagens do
salpo sobre tratamentos convencionais
ele é destacado como um suplemento
natural tem uma lista menor de efeitos
colaterais oferece uma opção alternativa
para melhorar a saúde da próstata de
forma natural e aumentasse também a
testosterona baixando o DHT então
estudos recentes sugerem que o sal
pometo Especialmente quando usado em
combinação com outros fitoterápicos e
suplementos como é o caso do celeno e
licopeno pode aliviar sintomas de dor
pélvica crônica melhorar a qualidade de
vida relacionado à saúde prostática
Então como o sal pento inibe a conversão
de testosteron e DHT o corpo pode reter
níveis normais de testosterona isso
ajuda na perda de peso no controle da
força na resposta à dor na perda de
cabelo e no desejo sexual então vamos
falar dos benefícios do uso de sal
pometo no caso específico do câncer de
próstata uma revisão de 11 estudos
identificou o sal paleto como uma das
cinco principais formas de medicina
alternativa que são adotadas por pessoas
que têm câncer de próstata pelos seus
efeitos antiinflamatórios principalmente
ele atua como inibidor natural da enzima
5 Alfa redutase Como já foi dito é
crucial essa enzima para conversão de
testosterone em DHT e o DHT ele vai
contribuir pro aumento da próstata e
possivelmente pro desenvolvimento do
Câncer então uma boa ideia utilizar esse
produto para pacientes com risco ou que
já tenha a doença como tratamento
complementar estudos sobre medicamentos
como a finasterida dutasterida mostraram
que homens que utilizaram Esses
medicamentos têm menor probabilidade de
desenvolver câncer de próstata em
relação aos que tomam Placebo no entanto
Existem os efeitos colaterais sexuais
são bem significativos também efeitos de
queda de de energia e de depressão Então
as vantagens do sal pometo além de
compartilhar os benefícios dos
inibidores farmacêuticos da cin Alf
redutase o salp palmito tem o benefício
adicional de não causar os mesmos
efeitos colaterais sexuais O que torna
uma alternativa muito mais atraente para
manutenção da função sexual de libido
Então esse
fitoterápico apresenta as probabilidades
de inibição do crescimento celular
cancerígeno estudo tem demonstrado que
esse sal pometo não só inbe o
crescimento das células de câncer de
próstata mas também pode destruir as
células perigosas bem pesquisas
realizadas na universidade de Pequim
destacaram a capacidade do sal palmeto
de interromper o crescimento de células
cancerígenas específicas e reduzir a
atividade do DHT de hidrotestosterona
outro estudo mostrou que o consumo de
sal palmeto diariamente durante dois
meses antes de uma cirurgia de próstata
pode S diminuir significativamente o
tempo de cirurgia e o tempo de
recuperação a suplementação com sal
pometo dem mostrou reduzir a perda de
sangue durante a operação diminuindo o
desenvolvimento de complicações
intraoperatórias e reduzindo também o
tempo total de permanência hospitalar
após a cirurgia o sal pometo pode ser
também uma ferramenta muito interessante
no tratamento da queda de cabelo da
calvice da alop androgenética que é
comum tanto em homens quanto mulheres e
se manifesta mais intensamente nos
homens devido aos níveis mais elevados
de testosterona que contribuem para a
calvice então é uma boa pedida aí para
quem tá sofrendo desse problema a queda
de cabelo normal é um processo de
renovação mais altos níveis de DHT ou de
testosterona poem interromper esse ciclo
o DHT se liga aos receptores
androgênicos aumentando a sua expressão
e promovendo a diminuição dos folículos
capilares O que impede o crescimento de
novos cabelos então o efeito salpo na
saúde capilar ele vai atuar como
inibidor natural da conversão de
testosterona em DHT ajudando a manter os
níveis sob controle O que é benéfico
para o crescimento do cabelo dos fios os
capilares um estudo na Clinical research
and development Network no Colorado
observou que o uso tópico de sal palmeto
em forma de loção em shampoo Aumentou a
densidade capilar em 35% dos
participantes após 3 meses de tratamento
uma revisão de 2020 consultando Básico
como cochran pubmed e Google scholar
indicou que o extrato sapeto melhora a
qualidade Geral do cabelo o número total
de fios e a densidade capilar em pessoas
com alopécia e qual que é a tolerância e
a segurança do trat com esse fito
terápico ele foi considerado bem
tolerado nos estudos com poucos ou
nenhum evento adverso grave relatado
fortalecendo no seu perfil como um
tratamento alternativo promissor eentão
uma boa porque tem poucos efeitos
colaterais como nós vamos falar os
efeitos mais frequentemente relatados
porém não são comuns são raros de sal
pometo como efeito colateral é
desconforto abdominal diarreia
constipação náusea fadiga dor de cabeça
e rinite o s sal palmeto pode não ser
seguro para uso durante a gravidez ou
amentação ele age como hormônio que pode
ser perigoso na gravidez portanto não
utilize sem consultar o médico antes
pessoas que usam anticoagulantes devem
evitar o uso do sal pometo isso porque
ele pode aumentar o risco de
sangramentos se você faz o uso desse
suplemento e pretende realizar alguma
cirurgia é importante parar de ingerir o
sal pometo pelo menos duas semanas antes
do procedimento compartilhe os vídeos
façil bem
a vida de alguém pode mudar também no
canal do além
do pessoal muito obrigado por ter
assistido esse vídeo você é fera e mora
no meu coração até o próximo vídeo